but this is being pushed at the
governmental level
then in this kind of middle ground at a
school in
minnesota so it's not quite the
government but it sort of is the
government
it's public and it's education is
coercive
there's a middle school teacher who is
teaching
children who are 11 to 13 years old who
is who is basing
at least one of his lesson plans around
praising
a transvestite prostitute take a look
now that we have
zoom school now that people aren't
really going into classrooms
you can watch some of these lessons take
a listen to mr
peruko's person of the day
so i apologize for the very long wait
for our suggester
but verucan's heruko's person of the day
is marsha p johnson
so if you don't know much about marshall
p johnson they were known as a fierce
advocate for gay rights
and aids as an aids activist and a
self-identified drag queen
in addition to all of their advocacy
marcia was also well known
for their president for their presence
at the stonewall uprising
and the subsequent demonstrations
throughout greenwich village
that protested the police raids that had
been taking place at local gay gathering
places
johnson's work paved the way for a
louder and more prominent voice in the
injustices that were being done
in and to the gay community the
interesting part here is that johnson
himself was actually discriminated
against by
the community uh for being a drag queen
in 1973 the committee in charge of a
pride parade
said that they were not going to allow
dre queens at the march
because they felt that they were giving
the community a bad name
that's actually a very telling aspect i
mean first of all this lesson plan is
obviously not
suitable for 11 year olds you should not
you know be
paying tax money and sending your kids
to schools so that your 11 year old
can hear hey geographies of transvestite
prostitutes that's
crazy but what he says there at the end
is he says you know actually
the gay community in the 70s didn't
really like this guy because
they thought it was it was like kind of
just too weird it was too out there
for the kind of activism they were doing
and you see the same
this same kind of issue today i mean
all of us have gay friends no gay people
and uh i have yet to encounter one of
them who say yeah this this whole
transgender movement where you're
forcing kids to learn this crazy
ideology and question their sex and
sometimes go on puberty blockers
that's great oh yeah man i love that
that's terrific
no of course and that there was that
tension going back to the 70s but right
now
the left the mainstream left schools
corporations the government is pushing
this kind of ideology on children and it
actually goes up
all the way to the federal level if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]
you